one of the very few things the interior
ministry fears is a Sheena her eyes
bloodshot with the waters of
rejuvenation Hashanah owes a lot to
these pure waters which have emboldened
her soldiers over the years some like
the terror troop are practically raised
on the persons that grow in them which
nourished them to monstrous proportions
others like
Genichiro imbibe the concentrated
sediment risking their humanity for the
way of the a Sheena victory at any cost
and a few lurking in deep caves and
distant forests do just the opposite
they risk the lives of others for the
sake of the self begin preparations yes
sir
preparing the rejuvenating water this
man
dojin and his split personality dose a
coup are almost certainly allied with
gana chato as they're experimenting with
the waters of rejuvenation in order to
push the human body further this they
believe is the only way to repel the
might of the Interior Ministry and it's
possible no it's easy to recruit one
such terror troop member for these
experiments because they're trusting
easily led and also distracted by some
mental anguish our subject is of large
stature and possesses near superhuman
strength this inspires confidence for
the glory of Hashanah this man is or was
named Cottenham proof it's not human not
anymore in the adjacent cell lies
another one of doujins prisoners and
before his death he managed to scrawl a
note about his adventures which reads
supposedly the fragrant stone is
enshrined in a village in the ash inner
depths but how do I interpret
throw oneself this is as far as that old
Okami tome could take me but did they
truly reach the fountainhead palace I'd
like to know
but it seems I never will this
adventurer was following the Okami on
their path to the Fountainhead like we
are but this is where his journey ended
what's tragic however is how he signs
off
it reads forgive me Katara thus the
former terror troupe member who was
transformed here is his son who was
foolishly led to this place because he
knows it's where his father went
tragically the journey of the father
dooms the son but it doesn't have to be
this way there is another path and it
starts with Cotto being taken to become
a monk to be taken is sort of like being
spirited away it's a supposedly
supernatural occurrence and when it
happens to you you're supposed to go to
the temple many choose to become a monk
here because the threat of being taken a
second time is very real and you might
just disappear like the rest of Kota
rows of friends they left me here where
did everyone go
why did you leave go to her behind no
what do I do
they left me all alone and I have to
find the pure white flower the pure
white flower flew away where could it be
when a child loses their life in service
to the monks experiments a flower or
pinwheel is planted
unfortunately koto doesn't recall this
as he suffers from the same sort of head
trauma that the rest of the Tarot troupe
do but bring the one white pinwheel to
Kota
and he'll remember the truth is this the
pure white flower oh wow that's
I remember now everyone they are
children of the rejuvenating waters and
I remember I tried to find the pure
white pinwheel a pinwheel for that child
a child of whom he speaks is the one who
received the rejuvenating Waters
successfully it's awoke a sort of
divinity in home an artificial form of
the dragon's heritage something that
Kuro has - I am one of the children of
the rejuvenating waters created by those
who would stop at nothing to achieve
immortality my false dragon's blood was
created by men children so there are
many of you I am the only one who
survived the process the others are laid
to rest here you see thankfully the
success of the experiment moved her to a
realm beyond that of the monks and now
she serves them no longer hey can I ask
a favor
what could you spirit me away I don't
follow
I know about you you're a shinobi right
those monks say she knew beacons spirit
people away make them disappear
as if they were never there why do you
want that oh I'm sure that everyone will
be wherever I disappear to and then I'll
get to see them I'm in charge of looking
after the children after all you can do
that right all right oh thank you thank
you I'm ready but also a little
frightened but yes do it
Kotaro oh it's you oh I'm glad you made
it look everyone mr. shinobi is here too
Oh children greet him properly hmm all
right you can't see them can you
the rejuvenated children yes you can't
see them but they're there they're
adorable kids right then I must give you
my thanks take this thank you so so much
[Music]
what is it the kids are saying thank you
too
they're so adorable and so Kotaro joins
the rejuvenating children and the divine
child in their lonely realm a place that
the divine child is finally thinking of
leaving I don't want to lose them but if
I were to choose the path of returning
the dragon's heritage it may come to
pass that I would have to leave all of
you but with Katara here to take care of
the children it should be easier for the
divine child to finally leave her
friends for in the end she leaves to
become a cradle for Lord Kuro embarking
with us on a dangerous journey to the
west our next adventure to return the
Dragons heritage if you watched this
video the week that it came out then the
next episode is actually already out and
you can watch it right now
it's just over on patreon I have a bunch
of reward tears over there
but I think that giving early access is
probably my favorite one because it
allows me to sort of demo my videos to a
small dedicated audience and then also
reward those people for helping to keep
the channel going so if you love from
Software's games go and check it out but
of course whether you're a patron or not
you'll get to see the video very soon
thank you for watching